[Musik]
bild key user
es ist also weit also soweit kanzler
scholz ist in kiew angekommen um 2 uhr
17 ging es für den kanzler ins
schlafabteil des sonderzugs nach kiew
neben dem deutschen kanzler sind auch
frankreichs präsident immer nur im makro
und italiens ministerpräsident draghi
dabei die drei wichtigsten staats und
regierungschefs europas werden also
gemeinsam jetzt verschiedene orte in der
ukraine besuchen 113 tage nach dem kreml
diktator wladimir putin das land
überfallen hat für alle ist es hier nun
der erste besuch in der ukraine seit
kriegsbeginn
und wir schauen zu paul ronzheimer live
zugeschaltet aus kiew paul also nun ist
olaf scholz endlich in kiew angekommen
er wird sich jetzt mit selensky treffen
was werden die zentralen themen sein
oder scholz ist in diesen minuten den
vier bahnen gekommen und man spürt die
anspannung hier schon in der stark es
gibt hohe sicherheits aufkommen und ist
hinter mir polizisten teilweise sind
straßen gesperrt worden da so olaf
scholz wird sich jetzt mit einem tross
also mit autos vom bahnhof auf den weg
machen auf eine erste station wo er sich
sicherlich noch einmal umziehen wird um
dann in richtung präsidentenpalast oder
aber das ist nicht ganz klar an einem
der orte zu fahren an die
regierungschefs die hier in kiew an
kommen traditionell fast fahren in den
vergangenen einem monat das ist entweder
butter also der ort der für
kriegsverbrechen der russischen armee
bekannt geworden ist oder eben nach ihr
team ebenfalls ein vor ort durch gestern
war unsere menschen gesprochen habe die
alle wünschen sich den besuch von olaf
scholz und sagen er muss das mit den
eigenen augen sehen gleichzeitig erleben
wir wie muss ja einmal kurz zur seite
wir erleben wie ihr vorbild ab
gleichzeitig erleben wir wie der tross
sozusagen hier natürlich in
in allen sicherheitsrelevanten
bereiteten sich vorbereitet dass es eben
nicht nur der deutsche bundeskanzler
sondern auch der italienische
regierungschef und der französische
staatspräsident da kann man sich
vorstellen wie viel sicherheit hier in
der stadt ist von den drei nationen ich
habe in den vergangenen tagen
italienische security französische
natürlich auch deutsche hier erlebt für
die beamten ist das pro komplex sie
müssen sich von verschiedenen orten an
andere orte bewegen und 1 darf man nicht
vergessen darin hat bürgermeister lied
stop gerade im gespräch mit mir ich habe
mit ihm telefonieren können doch einmal
erinnert sich kennen hat seien immer
noch raketen einschlagen zuletzt vor
einer woche also auf dieses risiko ist
nicht gebannt das heißt es muss auch
immer dann einen notfallplan geben zu
dem moment wenn die sirene heult dann
muss der bundeskanzler eigentlich in
einem keller in einem bunker das ist
natürlich auch eine planung die die
security hier treffen muss man hat ja
auch damals gesehen zum beispiel beim
besuch von stoltenberg auch damals sind
tatsächlich bei diesem besuch noch
raketen eingeschlagen
genau so ist es normalerweise ist es so
dass im zentrum keine erhöhte gefahr ist
also wenn man diesen reden hört in den
vergangenen wochen war es so dass
daneben vororte getroffen wurden das
natürlich genauso schlimm ist meistens
versucht die russische armee hier
militär punkte zumindest montiert ist es
so dass in den letzten wochen wenig
zivile einrichtungen getroffen wurden
aber wenn man versucht sozusagen
logistische zentrale punkte zu
beschließen wir gehen mal davon aus dass
bei einem besuch von metro oder scholz
und mario draghi sich die russische
armee zumindest was das angeht etwas
zurückhält denn möglicherweise wenn man
daran denkt dass mack und scholz häufig
mit la die mit guten telefoniert haben
könnte der ja auch ein interesse daran
haben dass die drei hier sind und
möglicherweise auch dinge sagen die
putin
erreichen will das ist unklar das
zumindest sorge hier auch im 4 das durch
die tatsache dass sie so viel kontakt
gab es zwischen wladimir putin und olaf
scholz und immer noch vor dass es da
auch um eine art ja
verhandlungsmöglichkeit geben könnte
immer wieder dass die rede von einem
neuen linz grün mit einer neuen sprache
das schreckenswort für die ukraine und
wir werden sehen was jetzt auch die drei
zu kommen fest steht dass es den das
gespräch mit demenz wie sicherlich auch
ein mittagessen geben wird und was
feststeht ist dass es auch eine
pressekonferenz geben soll mit den
dreien mit willen und das ist natürlich
schon ein großes zeichen der
unterstützung wir haben hier viele
staatschefs gesehen die nach ihren
kommen sind aber wir haben noch nicht
gesehen dass die drei mächtigsten
wichtigsten staatschefs aus europa
gemeinsam in kiew sind alle drei waren
seit kriegsbeginn noch nicht hier
glaubt man denn in der ukraine
tatsächlich noch auch an eine
diplomatische lösung oder geht es vielen
ski und pro tatsächlich hauptsächlich
darum jetzt nochmal europa zu sagen
menschen brauchen waffen wir brauchen
sie jetzt
diese menschen geht es ganz klar vor
allem um eines um waffen um
artilleriemunition das sind die dinge
die ihn im osten fehlen das muss man
immer wieder sagen auch wenn es hier
hinter mir in vier bis auf die
sicherheitsvorkehrung für den
bundeskanzler relativ normal aussieht im
osten ist das ganz anders das befinden
heftige kämpfe an einer frontlinie von
fast 1000 von fast 1500 kilometern statt
und da hat die russische armee gegen
großen vorteil in sachen artillerie in
großen vorteile in sachen munition und
fast verzweifelt sagen die ukraine wir
brauchen die waffen jetzt wenn wir uns
die waffen jetzt nicht schickt dann
werden wir überrannt dann drohen wir
weitere städte orte dort zu verlieren es
gibt heftige kämpfe jeden tag sterben
dort mindestens 100 italienische
soldaten und ist droht eben dass
russland den gesamten sommers ein
paul viel kritik hier eben auch für olaf
scholz in den letzten wochen in den
letzten monaten im vorfeld dieses ganzen
besuch ist was glaubst du wie wird er
sich jetzt geben bei dieser reise
ich denke dass alle ein interesse daran
haben das ist eine ja einen symbolischen
charakter hat dass man gemeinsam zeigt
dass man zusammen stets selensky hier
nochmal bei dem besuch versucht ja kurz
davor zu sagen was ihm nicht gefällt
olaf scholz den kannst du noch einmal
kritisiert zuvor hat darüber gesprochen
dass oder schaut sich entscheiden müsse
auf welcher seite er steht eben zwischen
deutschland zwischen frankreich und er
hat darüber gesprochen was am ende dafür
sorgen könnte ja hier unterstützung zu
bekommen er hat darüber gesprochen und
gesagt dass er waffen braucht und dass
ein weiteres thema ist die
eu-beitrittsperspektive nämlich die
frage ob die ukraine in die europäische
union gelassen wird beziehungsweise ob
es die perspektive gibt wenn die drei
sich dazu entschließen dann dauert das
ohnehin jahre zehn jahre 15 jahre bis
eine entscheidung über den tatsächlichen
beitritt vor dass es angesprochen nicht
immer warten sich europa einig in der
art und weise wie man mit diesen krieg
umgehen möchte wie einig sind sich denn
jetzt diese drei player scholz makro und
dran
die drei reisen hier gemeinsam hin nicht
nur weil sie die wichtigsten
regierungschefs in europa sind sondern
auch weil sie sich sehr einig sind in
ihrer art vorzugehen also über urlaub
shorts und dem handel marco habe ich
schon gesprochen sie telefonieren weiter
mit wladimir putin beide sind
zurückhaltend der so muss man es
formulieren bei waffenlieferungen olaf
scholz hat sich lange gesperrt auch
emanuel marco man sagen muss dass die
franzosen doch mehr liefern als
deutschland das sagen die ukraine
zumindest da geht es vor allem um
artillerie um die dinge die man dort an
der front braucht und wenn wir darüber
reden dass wir müssen jetzt mal ein
stück zurück wenn darüber reden das ist
eine unterstützungsleistung braucht also
wenn wir darüber reden das unterstützt
werden muss wir sehen das wird jetzt
hier sehr sehr leer hinter mir wir gehen
davon aus dass es demnächst sozusagen zu
einer ankunft kommen könnte in diesen
straßen wir sind hinter mir die straße
sind komplett leer mittlerweile also
alles gesperrt für diesen staatsbesuch
für die drei regierungschefs die hier in
jedem moment an kommen könnten und das
sind die drei regierungschefs die eben
besonders zusammenstehen emanuel account
oder scholz die telefonieren viel mit
wladimir putin sie sind zurückhaltender
bei der waffenlieferung mario draghi ist
da genauso insbesondere durch die
italienische öffentlichkeit die eher
kritisch gegenüber der ukraine ist da
geht es auch um gaspreise um ölpreise
das hat sich in italien noch viel
dramatischer entwickelt oder früher
dramatisch entwickelt als in deutschland
also deshalb auch die sorge der ukraine
dass man von diesen drei staatschefs
wenn sie jetzt doch am tisch sitzen und
gegenüber immerhin gegenüber
lohndifferenz geht der ukrainische
präsident sitzt dass diese drei druck
ausüben könnten was für ein grob wäre
das das wäre ein druck auf verhandlung
zu sagen es muss konzessionen geben zu
sagen man braucht ein modus operandi man
bau einen weg um jetzt eine lösung zu
finden aber das ist wiederum auch nicht
ohne risiko für die drei staatschefs
denn die öffentliche meinung in der
ukraine die steht dem entgegen und das
ist das große problem für vlotho
residenz die selbst wenn er das wollen
würde selbst wenn er sagen würde ja olaf
scholz ja immer noch immer krank ich
will auch jetzt mit ladino putin am
tisch setzen und verhandeln ich würde
diesen krieg sofort beenden die mehrheit
in der ukrainischen bevölkerung sagt
ganz klar russland hat uns angegriffen
russland hat dieser ort erobert wir
haben so viele menschen verloren freunde
familie ehefrauen kinder wie können wir
jetzt mit dem verhandeln deswegen ist
die forderung konsolen ski und die
russischen truppen müssten zurück hinter
die linie des 24 februars das war der
beginn des großen krieges davor gab es
ja bereits krieg im osten des landes und
dort war so dass dann ja man sagt er sie
müssen mario pulver lassen sie müssen
weitere städte die sie erobert haben im
osten verlassen das ist die forderung
der ukraine diese forderung scheint
momentan relativ unrealistisch wenn wir
darüber reden was wladimir putin tun
könnte von daher muss man abwarten was
sich jetzt aus diesen gesprächen ergibt
also wir gehen davon aus dass hier ist
in jedem moment hier die drei
staatschefs kommen können wir sehen die
website die hinter uns fährt und jetzt
sehen wie wir sehen die karossen hinter
unserer einfahren dann vielleicht
hättest du einmal drauf yoga store ist
was sie hier da kommt
das wollen wir auf jeden fall leisten
mitnehmen
da bleiben wir jetzt natürlich noch bei
der wir sehen also ein großes
presseaufgebot natürlich auch
rieseninteresse eben an diesen besucher
der 3
und jetzt haben wir eben auch limousinen
autos vorfahren in denen die drei
staatschefs dann tatsächlich auch sitzen
werden so wie wir das vermuten sagen wir
mal wer aus diesem wagen ist es als
erstes aussteigers gesehen wir sehen
also delegation die natürlich mit dabei
sind bei so einer reise da ist ganz viel
sicherheit mit dabei
ist
schulze wir jetzt gerade reingegangen
ist in das hotel
so ist es wir sehen hier die deutschen
wagen wie angekommen sind also das ist
jetzt die deutsche gruppe die dort
angekommen ist olaf scholz mit einer
tasche in der hand
haben wir gesehen wie er dort
eingestiegen ist und
wir sehen wir sehen sozusagen hier bei
der frage wer jetzt an kommt noch nicht
genau wo die franzosen
paul an man muss sagen wenn man sich
jetzt diese bilder gerade anschaut
menschen mit rollkoffern die in ein
hotel einen verein gehen und einchecken
strahlender sonnenschein man hat einfach
nicht das gefühl wenn man das von hier
aus sieht dass man in ein land blick das
mitten im krieg stecken das profil ist
das auch für dich dort vor ort zu sein
immer zwischen diesen beiden wirken
ja das ist eine möglichkeit natürlich
aber auf der anderen seite und das hat
vitali klitschko der bürgermeister von
kiew immer wieder dass es jederzeit zu
einem einschlag kommen kann also zu
einem raketeneinschlag und hier davon
nicht völlig befreit ist also wir sehen
jetzt hier wie die straße vollkommen
leer ist durch diesen besucher sehen
natürlich eine große sicherheit so viele
sicherheitskräfte
auch von der deutschen seite aber
natürlich auch von der ukrainischen
seite die jetzt den bundeskanzler
begleitet haben aber ganz wichtig zu
sagen natürlich riskiert nicht
vergleichbar mit der situation im ostend
ist nicht vergleichbar mit der situation
wenn man hier 800 kilometer rausfährt
ist momentan eine stadt die wieder zum
leben zurückgefunden hat aber die sorge
die ist so groß auch in kiew dass das
was hier passiert ist als wir dort waren
im februar im märz die russischen
truppen versucht haben diese stadt
einzukesseln dass das wieder passieren
könnte also dass es im osten voran geht
das ladegut ihn dort weiter erfolge hat
das er dann weitergeht in andere städte
nach delhi pro nach sabrina dass er
weiter gehen könnte um dann wieder auch
nach ihr zu kommen momentan sieht es
hier friedlich aus insbesondere im
zentrum aber das kann sich jederzeit
ändern wir sehen jetzt eine weitere
delegation die ankommt müssen schauen
nebenan das müssen entweder die
italiener seien oder die franzosen ich
glaube das sind ist die französische
delegation
und wir gehen einmal rein mit der kamera
ganz kurz jahres jetzt schauen wir
einmal dass wir auf das mitnehmen können
wie hier der französische
staatspräsident in diesem moment an bord
angesprochen die sicherheitsvorkehrung
natürlich enorm auch im vorfeld dieses
besuches sei aber sind denn inzwischen
gewisse einzelheiten über den verlauf
dieses besuches bekannt welche museen zu
werden wir sind jetzt immer wir sind
jetzt im akkord wir sind machen wir das
hotel betritt in diesem moment aber auch
er äußert sich nicht vor der presse
jetzt haben auch den französischen
präsidenten gesehen sind sagt dass paule
weiß man denn inzwischen wo die drei
dann auch auf präsident seelands die
treffen werden oder wird das aus
sicherheitstechnischen gründen noch
geheim gehalten
also der zeitpunkt wird geheim gehalten
man kann vielleicht eins sagen das hier
ist in den in der vergangenheit immer so
war dass diese treppen dann am ende im
präsidentenpalast statt gefunden haben
dass der palast wo ich würde mir so lenz
wie auch schon zwei mal interviewt habe
wir sehen jetzt den großen presse tross
des französischen staatspräsidenten die
mit ihm gereist sind in diesem nachtzug
ich kann sagen mit aus eigener erfahrung
da schläft man ganz gut wenn man aus
polen hiernach hier kommt das eigentlich
eine sehr gute anreise das ist die
delegation hier des französischen
staatspräsidenten moment und die ging
jetzt alle einmal sich frisch machen sie
sind und wir haben gelesen bei gehört
und angelika hellemann die sind seit
zwei uhr 17 unterwegs in diesem nachtzug
jetzt wird sich einmal frisch gemacht
und dann geht es los zu den termin und
paul inzwischen haben wir auch eine
erste reaktion von bürgermeister vitali
klitschko bekommen die wollen wir ihnen
natürlich nicht vorenthalten ich bin als
bürgermeister glücklich und stolz sagte
er dass der deutsche bundeskanzler
zusammen mit dem französischen
staatspräsidenten und den italienischen
regierungschef unsere stadt besucht das
ist ein zeichen großer unterstützung in
einer zeit in der es immer noch ein
risiko ist kiew zu besuchen denn es
können weiter jederzeit raketen
einschlagen der besuch hat vor allem
große symbol bedeutung und zeigt die
unterstützung für die ukraine in zeiten
des krieges stabilität in europa kann es
nur dann geben wenn putin diesen
grausamen krieg gegen unser land endlich
beendet paula wenn du dir diese worte
anhörst der sagt ja es ist auch ein
symbolischer besuchen sagt allerdings
olaf scholz ist soll eben kein arena
fototermin werden und setzt sich damit
natürlich auch selber ein bisschen unter
druck wenn es kein foto termin werden
soll was denn dann was hat er dabei
ich nehme an olaf scholz bereut diesen
satz bereits wieder den er dort
gesprochen hat das war ja die begründung
warum man nicht hierher fahren wollte
wir erinnern uns wir hatten damals bei
bild diese geschichte exklusiv dass
steinmeier ausgeladen wurde von bruno
missler lenski und dann gab es diesen
streit dieses hin und her wenn wir jetzt
darüber sprechen jetzt gibt es wieder
bewegung ich nehme an dass auch der
italienische regierungschef mario draghi
ehemaliger ezb-chef übrigens und
deswegen gut bekannt auch mit olaf
scholz zu einer zeit als finanzminister
hier gleich anreisen wird man muss eines
ganz klar sagen der druck ist gewaltig
der druck ist groß dass dann auch am
ende was passiert das was warum kommt
dass zumindest die ukraine sagen können
jetzt sehen wir mario trage hier
ankommen in diesem moment die
italienische flagge weht dort und wir
zeigen auch natürlich die ankommt
der paul
der dritte delegation am hotel
angekommen das auto von mario draghi
sehen wir gerade
vorfahren der italienische
regierungschef wird dann eben jetzt auch
dann auf seine zimmer gehen nehmen wir
mal an und sich ein wenig frisch machen
nach diesen vielen stunden im nachtzug
von polen dann auf dem weg nach kiew du
hast ja angesprochen mitten in der nacht
sind die drei eingestiegen und wir haben
ja auch die live fotos da schon gesehen
gehabt wir haben sich hier
offensichtlich auch schon in der nacht
sehr viel unterhalten und diesen besuch
gemeinsam
abgestimmt also ob die da so viel
geschlafen haben das weiß man dann auch
nicht aber was man weiß paul ist bleibt
nicht viel zeit zum ausruhen es wird
relativ schnell weitergehen
[Musik]
momentan
micron olaf scholz
die machen das ist natürlich
etwas ganz ganz groß ist ein großer
tross auf er hat viele sicherheitssparte
dabei wir sehen hier sowohl
haben wir die alle dabei sind hier bei
diesem besuch und wenn wir das jetzt
anschauen dann muss man sagen dann muss
man sagen das
[Musik]
nur mit makro fahren könnte aber jetzt
wissen wir wir sind zu dritt und sie
sind zu dritt hier angekommen und jetzt
geht es von hier an den nächsten ort
also von hier geht es los und von hier
wird jetzt diese delegation aufbrechen
das ist geheim da können wir nicht
drüber berichten live zumindest nicht da
geht es an einen ort entweder wird man
jetzt erst so lenz gefahren oder man
wird an einen der orte an einem der
vororte fahren bouchareb linie finden
dieser ort wo ich noch gestern waren mit
den menschen gesprochen habe paul m die
menschen denn ihr team mit denen du
geredet hast was erwarten sie sich von
diesem besuch oder erwarten sie
eigentlich gar nichts mehr nachdem sie
ja nun auch von sehr vielen ansagen aus
europa enttäuscht wurden
da gibt es hohe erwartungen natürlich an
den bundeskanzler von das muss man immer
wieder sagen deutschland steht hier im
zentrum wenn ich über die straße gehe
und deutsch sprechen dann sprechen mich
die leute an und sagen war auch super
toll so wenig das mag und versand ist
aber die realität in der ukraine über
frankreich über italien wird nicht so
viel gesprochen die experten sagen wir
frankreich liefert auch etwas mehr also
die klare erwartungshaltung der menschen
in der ukraine ist dass es mehr waffen
für den osten gibt dass der osten
verteidigt wird dass russland nicht noch
mehr gebiete dort erobern kann und es
ist sehr emotional vorn
paul du wirst diesen besuch natürlich
ganz nahe für uns begleiten wir machen
eine ganz kurze pause sind aber
natürlich sofort wieder bei dir
[Musik]